welcome
tonight's lecture
a manual fatigue
is well known to many of us in this hall
associate professor of architecture
Emmanuel petit holds the diploma and
architecture from the eighth a.ha
Switzerland where he studied under Mario
comfy Vittorio Manya no Lampoon Yanni
and Kurt Forster after completing his
studies there in Switzerland
professor petit went on to Princeton
where he received his Master of
Architecture and in 2006 his PhD in
history and theory of architecture with
a thesis on irony during the rising
years of post-modernism a thesis that he
developed under a committee consisting
of Beatrice kala Mina Stan Allen
Eduardo Kodava and Edward eigen
professor petit was first introduced to
Yale as Peter you know nachos they said
don't touch it you mean I have to do
this all over again
my public demands that they hear every
word of this professor petit was first
introduced to Yale as Peter Eisenman's
assistant teacher in advanced studios
since then he has joined the faculty
offering an undergraduate studio as well
as graduate level lecture courses
seminars and studios in 2006 Emanuel
organized the symposium Philip Johnson
the constancy of change and ended the
book edited the book of the same title
published by Yale University Press in
2009 a wonderful publication he has
established articles in important
scholarly journals and we look forward
to the publication in 2011 by Yale
University Press of his book irony or
the self-critical opacity of postmodern
architecture which is based on his PhD
thesis at Princeton professor petits
scholarly activities have been
accompanied by professional practice he
has worked for Eisenman architects at
the liege on nouvelle and since 2009 has
been in partnership with rally
poteete in the firm episteme architects
tonight professor pootie will elaborate
on the exhibition now in our gallery an
exhibition that he curated and and
co-designed with Dean Sakamoto in which
he presented work and which is presented
work of over 70 students who studied
with James Stirling over the course of
that distinguished teachers long
association with Yale this lecture
concludes tonight's electric includes a
series of lectures and conversations on
sterling that have been jointly
organized by our school and the Yale
Center for British art celebrating a
great architect and teacher I want to
thank the staff of the British Art
Center especially its director Amy Myers
for their amazing good work in bringing
the James Stirling show to profession
and to thank Tony viddler its curator as
well as many others especially Mirko
sardini director of the Canadian Centre
for architecture now it is my pleasure
to introduce a manual petit whose talk
is titled synchrony and diachrony James
Stirling students at Yale Emmanuel
Thank You Dean Stern for the
introduction but also for asking me to
curate the exhibition that is on the
second floor I certainly learned a lot
not not only about Stirling himself but
also about the history of our school and
the institutional and ideological
changes that happened throughout the
four dean ships that sterling lived
through from Paul Rudolph to Charles
Moore to Hermann Spiegel and to Caesar
Pelli
also I enjoyed meeting some of the
people who offered their views on the
subject of Jim's
looking looking through the James
sterling and Michael Wilford fair in
preparation of the symposium on sterling
we held here in the school in the spring
of 2009
I also thank Dean Sakamoto
who designed to show upstairs for a
great collaboration and David Reinhart
who acted as my research assistant for
all of this and perhaps most of all I
thank the alumni of Stirling Studios who
were so kind to give us their drawings
without them there would be no show
upstairs and no lecture tonight here is
a photo of the subject sterling dressed
as father Christmas at the American
Academy in Rome in 1983 with a stage set
painted by none other than frank stella
a kind of gestural and abstract winter
scene to stage sterling we heard a lot
about Jim sterling in the last month by
Tony Villa Bob Maxwell Michael Wilfred
Peter Eisenman caught foster a sequence
of arguments which it is really really
difficult to follow
yet the focus of my talk will be
different in the sense that I will
address the architectural thought of
sterling of course but I will do that
mostly via other people's work
sterling students who he meant out here
at Yale in his 24 years of teaching
between 1959 and 83 the study of the
drawings in sterling studios literally
opens a different perspective on the
subject however I do not want to repeat
the thematic of the exhibition itself
and also of my essay in the exhibition
pamphlet and will therefore not rehearse
the chronological and systematic paths
that you see upstairs in the exhibit but
will follow a more analytical nonlinear
and selective approach to specific
documents in the exhibit and the archive
which we build up in its context I think
one of the most provocative aspects of
Sterling's architecture and aspect over
which his critics divided into two camps
is that some like to insist
more that he was interested in the
metaphysics of the building as an object
while others maintained that his
contribution was directed at the urban
texture his architecture participated in
while the former category focuses on a
time that is internal to the object
the latter deals with a more historical
extrinsic and episodic notion of time in
architecture if we had to suggest iconic
precedents for both of these aspects of
sterling Auguste rezzie's abstract
analysis of ancient architecture in the
second half of the 19th century could be
representative of the first category the
idea of an internalized time while
Giambattista knowledge transcription of
the texture of Rome in the mid 18th
century can stand for the idea of an
anecdotal time of the building that is
directly related to the city on the one
hand the worm's-eye axon of choir's ii
became codified as carrying the code of
hellenic reality
in architecture when choise he used it
to convey his analysis of the Athenian
Acropolis showing the strong link
between the compositional grammar of the
plan and the a visual effect of the
volumes and elevations in space Robert
Kahn who studied here was sterling in 79
and was one of his teaching assistants
in nine in 1983 only confirmed his
influence on sterling when he told me
that sterling used the pun that the
worms eye view makes architecture fly
off into space
tacky isn't it
I'm aware of it the Dean hates it sure
enough choise he also analyzed the
promenade that lead from one such space
to the next famously also when he mapped
out the Acropolis but that path to was
described in terms of the intrinsic
order of the architectural objects along
the promenade famously Luke obg
referenced treci in Varanasi Tech 2 and
explained in the caption of schwoz's
diagram that the seeming disorder of the
plan of the Acropolis will fool only the
profane on the other hand the nollie map
does not stress a reality but brings out
the Faculty of the public urban spaces
that are in place and illustrates that
they are in fact and factually already
part of an urban network of
relationships in existence the
difference can be expressed in very
simple terms Swasey is looking up into
the metaphysical realm of the object the
intrinsic if you want while nolley is
looking down onto the physical spaces of
the actual city choosing sides in this
discussion conventionally meant that you
had to pick either the Leicester Oxford
and Cambridge buildings of Sterling as
the epitome of his legacy or else you
would side with his more narrative
German projects from the Distilled of
Cologne and stuck-up museums to the
vision shaft sent home in Berlin or his
entry for the competition of the French
national library of course this one was
not in Germany but he lost the
competition precisely I would claim
because it was based on an anglo-saxon
sense of sonography and width
transplanted into the emotional heart of
French national pride Paris freely shyly
can figure as a precedent of Sterling's
idea of the scenography amassing the
you know graphic amassing of fragments
on the rhetorical stage of
representation the romanticism of the
fragmented scheme was incompatible with
French cartesianism but I would claim
that Sterling's architectural
idiosyncrasies hinge on this
double-consciousness in architecture to
document this Sterling was no doubt
interested in the core vision a reality
of joie see Swasey as an example of the
masterly
correct and magnificent play of masses
brought together in light as kobe gia
put it yet at the same time the
down-to-earth sterling the son of an
engineer appropriates other aspects from
choix see be interest in the materiality
of the brick the tectonic assemblage of
physical elements the joints between
them and the analytical mindset that
discerns the elemental and finite
ingredients of an architectural thing as
opposed to the infinite and absolute of
an architectural idea this is schwoz's
analysis and fragmentary axon of the
tectonics of the Parthenon south wall
and we know from Sigmund Freud and his
parallel analysis of dream imagery and
jokes
that a high potential for a rich imagery
with multiple and possibly contradictory
meanings is given when high thought and
low facts of life collide when
compositional ideas meet the tectonics
of the brick so to speak the stones
tumbling out of the wall in the
Stuttgart Museum are only the most
graphic translation of this idea of high
meeting low both types of documents the
ones that look up both literally and
also metaphorically and those that look
down exist in Sterling these are some of
Sterling's drawings for his lost this
world of museum competition as you know
which I consider as his pivotal and
defining project
and you literally see the central role
the frame blueSky plays in these as the
signifier of the infinite and possibly
of the ideal the detached the absolute
we also know that a circle is a
recurring motif in sterling to stress
geometrically the idea of the center
which is able to organize and give
orientation to the more peripheral
geometries around it and we heard in
previous talks how instrumental Colleen
row was in introducing sterling to
nollie and the idea of the weaving of
inside and outside spaces into the
continuum of the public surfaces of the
city here is distilled off again but
this axon looks down and you see how the
context and reality of the city reappear
the historic houses some in ruin as you
know the materiality of the pavement
trees sidewalks and even the tables and
chairs of the museum cafe become visible
while the view up distills a sort of
architectural DNA only those select
motifs that seem essential to the
project as an idea are being shown the
view down shows the building in its
entirety its actual look the factual
phenomenon before I dive in to show you
drawings of Sterling students let me say
something about the title of my talk
just three sentences
I picked the tile in reference to the
expression synchronous diachrony the
Russian literary theorist and formalist
Mikhail Bakhtin
coined bactine analyzed those linguistic
structures that hinge on a certain
density and multiplicity of
contradictory meanings the
conglomeration of languages both high
and low that can mean in heterogeneous
ways simultaneously that condense all
the different meanings that can normally
only succeed one another in time in one
sic present-moment a kind of spatial ice
time or vertical time as bactine calls
it
I put forward that back teens
complementary model of synchronous
diachrony is the most productive way to
conceptualize the idea Stirling conveyed
in his architecture and his teaching now
let me illustrate how these ideas can be
extracted from the drawings of Stirling
students he at Yale and how they help us
expand the reading of Stirling here is a
drawing by Paul Rosenblatt who took his
studio in the fall of 1983 when studying
a sign the Performing Arts Center at
Cornell as the studio problem the
drawing is remarkable because it creates
the apparatus fusion of the two
temporalities I mentioned before with
schwa C and nollie the axon which you
know was a fixture in Sterling's own
work and also in his studios here at
Yale is hinged which means that you are
looking at the same space of a rosin
that's building twice both up into the
round lantern like skylight and at the
same time also down into the more
meandering entrance hall with its
connections to adjacent spaces in other
words Rosenblatt's drawing unites the
features of both mercy and nalli of the
absolute time of the Platonic form of
the round Lantern closed on itself that
round form closed on itself and looking
up with the episodic time of the
labyrinthian entrance hall that is meant
to be transitioned through and that is
inserted in the network of the public
spaces of the urban context this one is
looking down no doubt Roe is behind this
double-consciousness
and we know how another individual who
was close to role at Cornell has
produced a similar double axonometric
drawing that suggests architecture
simultaneous orientation up into ideal
space and also down into actual or
pragmatic space this one from 1979 of
course is by REM koolhaas and the office
for metropolitan architecture for the
addition to a panopticon prison built in
eighteen
- in arnhem in the netherlands this
project fuses jeremy bentham's utopian
party of the panopticon paradoxically
with OMS pragmatic version of a prison
based on linear corridors that lead out
underneath Bantam centrifugal space and
thus negates its utopian paradigm but
those these projects that axis here that
double axe is here and that enclosed
shape they can coexist simultaneous
simultaneously in a kind of spatialized
time building but let's return to
Rosenblatt Smithsonian space what he did
and OMA did not do is to create the
spatial hinge here which graphically
connects the two exon drawings here is
the plan so that you can orient yourself
and in fact that hinge that we are
looking at is is one amongst is only one
hinge and there are two hinges this one
is more active in the XY plane and
rotates some of the the field of the pan
grid out of the orthogonality and this
hinge is a spatial hinge I want to claim
that for this particular solution which
is so helpful in figuring out what
Sterling's architectural Weltanschauung
was about the context of Yale was very
important and this is for the reason
that Josef Albers who taught at Yale
from 1950 to 58 provided the structural
and aesthetic mechanism to make this
double drawing work meaning the drawing
that allows you to look up and down at
the same time these structures are taken
from Albert series entitled structural
constellations on which he worked while
he was at Yale you can assume that
sterling had been influenced by Albers
formal experimentations in the 50s
himself as we know that a pinwheel
dynamic and the alternating up-and-down
movement in space has been part of
Sterling's interest ever since his ever
since his and James Cohen's assembly
hall project in camber
in London the date of this project is
1958 to 61 so right after Albus had come
up with these drawings Rosenblatt
confirmed to me that he was influenced
by Albus and also by the American
graphic designer and Cooper Union
professor Rudolph de Herrick who was
also a visitor here at Yale and for whom
Rosenblatt worked during some of his
summers these are some of the Herricks
book designs and you see the the cover
of Paul Valerie's mr. tests in fact mr.
test is mr. head whose whole existence
is given up to the examination of his
own intellectual process so you get the
trope of self-examination and analytical
self and folding the lived or anecdotal
life of mr. heads and at the same time
the idealized analysis of that life at
the same time I also want to mention MC
Escher's play with the graphic
representation of spaciality as another
precedent when 2d drawings turned
spatial and when spatial objects are
transcribed into flat representations
certain impossible translations can
happen a translation between the world
of 3d things out there and the world of
ideas conceptualized in the 2d surface
of a drawing the potential for miss
reading when 2d and 3d fuse is part of
the intellectual potential of the
artistic activity and had an influence
on sterling too let's remember that in
his essay real and English Peter
Eisenman had argued precisely that at
Leicester Stirling himself plate was the
linguistic with the sorry with the
intrinsic flatness of glass sheets when
he rendered them paradoxically spatial
sculptural and massive now here is a
drawing by Richard Clarke for the Stars
gallery in Stuttgart which sterling
assigned in the studio in 1978 there are
conceptual analogies with Rosenblatt's
drawing I just showed you Clark wanted
to capture he told me though
the analytical and the experiential
aspects of the architecture as they
coexist and hence the drawing combines
the effect of the axonometric built
around an infinite vantage point with
the technique of perspective built
around specific viewpoints in real space
several viewpoints and drawing
techniques merge in the same document
that no longer just has an equivalent
out there in real space but builds its
own architecture of representation so
what you get is the impression that you
are faced with some kind of worms eye
view reminiscent of schwa see yet you
are looking down into the space the
project is built into the earth Clarke
insisted and every column is constructed
around a different vantage point sliding
along the central axis that red axis
which in fact represents the movement
axis of the museum visitor so the
perspective of the drawing shifts with
the actual movement of the visitor to
this museum of course why the movement
of a person unfolds in time in
historical time in a sequence of
diachronic events Clarke's drawing
absorbs that movement in the
simultaneity of his representation it
becomes the hinge that chains these
discrete moments together the visitor
enters the building where I put the blue
arrow looks at a white wall panel then
changes direction at the crossing
between the high post aisle on the one
hand and that linear colonnade and
chooses between ascending to the light
the light of the galleries and the
sculpture court this is a perspective of
the sculpture quote once you go up the
stairs here all penetrating the wall to
the dark elements of the program like
the theater and the galleries for
graphic art and alike the point being
that this space like so many instances
of Sterling's own architecture creates
the simultaneity of heterogeneous
elements and experiences and the drawing
is based on a graphic structure that
makes this heterogeneity work
despite the overall symmetry of the plan
the promenade it sets in motion is
fundamentally asymmetrical and episodic
two types of axonometric the ones
looking up and the ones looking down can
be found throughout Sterling studios
they help to calibrate the architectural
intentions this is worth mentioning just
because it is not just part of the
graphic standards of all studios on the
one hand you will find the worm's-eye
views which insist on the notion of
abstraction here is one by Kevin Smith
your view is pulled up towards the
dashed lines the dashed lines that
circumscribed the extruded half cylinder
of the skylight a geometrically pure
glass element that crowns the complex
geometry underneath it and literally
accepts the role of the whipped cream on
top of the marble cake by distilling the
heterogeneous composition of the base
into the clarity of a pure form floating
on top and here is a worm's-eye in
isometric by Walter Lee bender again we
have similar tropes at play than in the
previous example this time around tower
a square tower and an l-shaped corner
volume they are all three volumes
transpire from a common resume attic
connector and reveal their volumetric
purity as they rise up even though moved
on to work for us atmosphere Tsongas
right after graduation from Yale and he
participated in the design of the messy
tall high-rise in Frankfurt this was a
year after this was a few years after
Angus left Cornell as the chair of the
department of architecture from 69 to 75
I am mentioning Angus because he of
course loved the view up so to speak
up towards abstraction and conception
you just need to see how he has his
buildings photographed Angus was not
interested in squaring the circle which
architects had already become really
good at in the context of Italian
humanism just consult Rudolph it curve
on that but unga's was interested in
revealing the true squareness of the
square quite an intellectual feat and
exercise in self flagellation
for sure this example examples very much
emphasized the idea of inferiority of
the object and fold it onto itself in an
abstract space a space with no
distractions of context but then there
are those axons that looked down to
connect to gravity and to the historical
palin test of the real city this is an
example taken from the very first studio
sterling tortilla in the fall of 1959
this one by James McNeely the
architecture and urbanism is no doubt
closer to Paul Rudolph than it is to
Sterling not only did Rudolph Wright the
studio briefs in Sterling's early
teaching years here in the late 1950s to
the mid-60s but sterling acted more as a
visiting consultant then as the master
studio critic sometimes joined by King
Louie you but one sees how the axon is
used to contextualize the building of a
hotel tower in New Haven where the Omni
Hotel is now in its urban surrounding
the vegetation the sidewalk even people
appear or another example is the exon of
Joan of George Turnbull's addition to
the building we are in Rudolph's back
then a na building this drawing is 15
years after the previous one and there
and again the axon contextualizes the
architectural intervention in the
physical and labyrinthian spaces of the
city with its trees shrubs sidewalks and
garden walls of course the axon doesn't
acquire the full texture of life that
inhabits these spaces as the perspective
would by the way here you see how
Charles Moore still has a kind of
influence here with this symbolic
scaffolding that signifies entrance to
the building and a few years later again
Mack balls exon gives tactile quality to
the space surrounding his buildings the
clouds with their shadows on the ground
the texture of the pavement of the
spaces and so on in his essay
perspective as symbolic form Ervin
Panofsky wrote that a structure of an
infinite unchanging and homogeneous
space and that includes exons ensure the
purely mathematical space is unlike the
structure the structure of
psychophysiological space perception
does not know the concept of infinity
Mack balls drawing is constructed around
an infinite vantage point it's an axon
and so on the one hand it inherently
denies the connection to the real world
as did Rosenblatt's drawing and Richard
Clarke's to a degree and yet on the
other hand ball also makes the drawing
tactile and in Panofsky terminology
provides traces of the
psychophysiological the suggestion of
the phenomenology of clouds their
shadows and the dark sky it might you
might even suggest that it is raining
just look at the the length under and
the direction of the pencil strokes in
fact ball makes sure that infinity the
inherent structure of his drawing is
complemented with the type of
information that returns destroying to
the finite space down here we know this
type of ambivalent dual orientation
towards a reality on the one hand and
actuality on the other from John Hay
dark series of wall houses you see how
the abstract from the nineteen 1970s of
course wall has to and the ambiguity
house and you see how the abstract
drawings of the plan and the axonometric
are nested paradoxically in nature with
its phenomenological texture the clouds
and the trees which even lent a figural
quality to certain volumes of hadix
architecture so this is taken from that
from the here and now not from some big
idea in Hajduk this table orientation
was argued to be the basis for the
complex meaning of poetry a meaning that
is neither simply abstract and ideal not
just real and concrete we know from a
sketch alex colin submitted to us by the
way that Hajduk was very explicitly a
ref
in Sterling studios in the late 1970s
here golian analyzes the wall houses and
you see how on top of the sheet and I
pulled that out he lays open what he
calls the philosophical concept and
explains that the presence this porous
time stuck in between the past and the
future is least stable
I assume this is a different way of
explaining that architecture is that
connector that mediator between the
fragments of reality and history and the
absoluteness of ideas that are yet to
come that are being projected in both
mac balls and Sterling's plans for the
Florence Government Center a series of
geometrically abstract calls are strung
together in a series of episodes
Sterling's
scheme is more clear in that respect and
mcpoyles also defines a series or a
sequence of small centers that are
strung together so on the one hand these
calls have a recognizable Gestalt in
each case and their internal temporal
'ti yet the schemes are not simply
closed unto themselves but they already
contain the grammatical rules for future
expansion for the absorption of the
episodic narrative time of an expansion
in other words while these formula
islands have a strong and have a strong
core identity the synapses between these
individual moments are quite flexible
and accepting for future development the
process of historic time is in the sense
anticipated and what I just described
with urban design can also be found in
architecture this is the top view of a
model of Alex : for the extension of
Harvard's Fogg Museum in Cambridge the
studio problems sterling assigned in the
fall of 1979 UC skylights in the form of
three platonic shapes the circle the
square and the diamond strung together
by the envelope of the building in fact
structurally the chain of platonic forms
in the building is not so different from
mcpaul sequence of urban centers gone in
three forms don't only appear on the
roof of
building but they they organized the
whole plans of the building in one of
the early sketches you see how Gul
inputs the series a series of platonic
volumes of in front of a stage set like
surface very reminiscent of the party
Luka BG a Salvation Army building in
Paris so here you have that surface and
these elements that are lined up in
front of that stage set in the last
month Tony Villa has emphasized several
times the relevance of the Salvation
Army party to Sterling's buildings
claiming not least that avoided drum in
the center of the starts gallery was
ultimately taken from this ROM Kabu goal
in shapes appear just like in the Kobe G
as the pure volumes playing off the flat
plain and those forms are meant to be
transitioned through the representation
is an isometric which which is
disconnected from the particular contour
of the urban site and makes that
geometric discrepancy quite evident this
sketch addresses the realm of IDI
allottee that is not yet adjusted to
meet that contingent the contingent
geometries of the city but then as Colin
gets closer to his final project
something happens in his design which is
not Co vision at all but very much in
line with what sterling would do the
simple volumes get wrapped in an
envelope which aligns itself with the
contour of this of the street this
facade does not only mediate between the
reality of the Platonic volumes and the
reality of the city but its surface gets
filled with the dense and multifarious
texture of an architectural rhetoric the
rhetoric of urban multiplicity here
extracted arguably from a venetian
Basanti an architectural ECOMOG Rafi
possibly it was the bridge that connects
the the Sackler museum to the fog that
evoked the Rialto in Venice and hence
some of the arrival and horseshoe arches
of the reality of surrounding buildings
get invoked by Gaul
on his facade where the site ends
because the street cuts it off
continuity is established with other
means with the bridge on the one side
this one connecting the settler museum
to the fog that is that bridge was never
realized in Sterling's own project as
you know and around the corner up here a
continuity suggested with a round
building that can act as a formal hinge
to connect to the next urban artifact
that might appear in the future
sterling did this too perhaps most
graphically in his mind occurs as a
project in Berlin in 1976 you see how
this project depends on the pragmatic
linkage of individual and recognizable
architectural objects you can identify
that means that means come in turn
Monument pyramids and other
architectural objects that are normally
freestanding after lining up this
catalog of autonomous and independent
objects extracted from different parts
of history with their internal object
temporalities he then introduces a
continuous street front which Springs
the history of architecture to get
together as a street you recognize the
facades of lukovitch's Philistine or
Remini san carlo and other paradigmatic
moments of architectural history not
least the Parthenon finally to turn the
corner
sometimes the rhetoric the the
rhetorical facades create these urban
continuity and sometimes the more
tectonic and grammatical hinges connect
connect the discrete parts goal in
sketches reveal this double aspect of
Sterling's that architecture produces
the simultaneity of diachronic ideas
meaning independent architectural events
that were conceived in subsequent
moments in history can now be chained
together in the synchronous time of the
urban street not only is the Sackler
here linked to the fog but also local
bridges carpenter center
is made part of that that link and also
John Andrews gondhal Gantt Hall which
houses the GSD of that educational
institution up north whose name won't be
mentioned
Golan suggested architecture
materializes as the physical and
pragmatic linkage of discrete
architectural forms quite literally
architecture becomes a bridge between
one spatial event and the next and you
see that for this idea the difference
between the spaces inside buildings
because this is a building and the
spaces in between buildings meaning the
street space that they are given
conceptual equivalents one can find
analogous ideas about how to structure
space on both the architectural and the
urban scales when the concept of
infinity and the fact of spatial
boundary are brought in dialogue with
one another and that is of course what
I'm maintaining is the guiding idea in
Sterling's architecture form appears in
fragmented in the fragmented state it
claims its autonomy and at the same time
indicates its finitude limits its
contingencies as well as its willingness
to act as a hinge in relation to
neighboring forms and other ideas to
competition projects for historic town
centres which sterling assigned when his
office was concurrently working on them
represent a turning point for Sterling
in this respect they are the new Civic
Center in Derby and the Distilled of
Museum these are from nineteen seventy
and seventy five respectively this is
Derby his Derby solution Sterling's own
project for Dobby as much as his student
projects hinge on a double urban theme
on the one hand a strong recognizable
form suggests a Center as the marker of
urban community and place and that is
here this horseshoe shape now here's Ron
Gonzalez's urban plan for Dobby and very
similarly you can see that strong form
can see how he quite clumsily nests a
circle into the urban fabric before this
autonomous form then accepts the
heterogeneous cumulation of different
building programs and types somehow
connected to the circles periphery so
all these different buildings they only
now belong together because that circle
indicates that that it is a hinge
between that heterogeneity and as if
making a point about the urban
simultaneity of different temporal
episodes like in Sterling's project
Gonzalez leaves the historical facade of
the old burned down Assembly Hall
standing
tangentially to the circle so the
infinite and unfolded figure of the
circle is now bounded by a finite and
accidental form like the fragmentary
remains of a historical building at the
same time the circle becomes the fal
chram and mediator between very
different building typology 'z and
public spaces you can see how this
Publix a Plaza is in fact a grammatical
blue between rattly radically
heterogeneous elements both
stylistically and historically also
heterogeneous notwithstanding definite
differences between the darby projects
and Sterling's early Leicester building
the idea of the hinge of FAL chrome is
recurring these diagrams show and these
diagram studies are taken from Peter
Eisenman's ten canonical building book
and you can see how the FAL chram makes
possible the coexistence of all these
different shapes that don't have that
much in common except their specific
relationships in to the rotational axis
in the project for the distal DAF Museum
Stuart silk invokes the geometrical form
of the circle to organize the plan of
his building but then breaks its
integrity very much like what he does to
the historical fire and facades that are
left over on the site here the circle is
broken and the facade is broken he
leaves them in the state of ruin broken
marking that they are part of the past
architectural paradigm that
and subsist but in a state of
fragmentation the broken circle suggests
in a more abstract way what the ruined
facade says in a more lyrical way which
is that the architectural present is a
mere hinge between a multiplicity of
temporalities and is part of the
continuum of history as you zoom in on
the plan of silks building you see how
he does not only use the circle once but
multiple times and a different scales in
the composition of his plan and each
time the circle is fragmented in one or
another way and questions the autonomy
of its form each architectural episode
is made part of a greater composition in
fact silk revisited the artistic
inventions of constructivism which
sterling already admired when he
conceived his earlier buildings in
Leicester and Cambridge and silks plan
illustrates the continued influence of
this artistic avant-garde in Sterling's
teaching the canvas is here taken from
Alexander rozhenko and the dynamism is a
commentary on the analogies he saw
between the laws of formal composition
on the one hand and the function and
individual being plays in the political
construction of society on the other
this former precedent in a way is
encoded with a certain ideology of the
polis one that speaks of the role an
individual voice and the voice of the
artist and the voice of one building
plays within the collective of the city
how individual autonomy can subsist in
the collective project of the city while
hierarchy and autonomy exist as an idea
and an intention both now find a way to
be woven into the fabric of the public
place the equivalence and exchange
ability of mass and void which was so
important to Sterling's architecture in
Dusseldorf and Beyond is also visible
here in silk these ideas can also be
traced back to the thought behind Roch
anko's very conceptual speculations on
the circle the circle conceptualized as
perimeter as disc a cylinder or as black
hole
respectively you also realize in this
axon that the formal device of a square
is suggested in the plan but then it is
fragmented to adjust to the specific
contours of the site so again the ideal
form of the square that is then broken
to adjust to the specificity of the city
that it is part of in Rodchenko the
circle never comes alone and hence the
notion of self identity is questioned in
Sterling too the circle is always made
part at a syntactic field of figures
every part gets its identity from the
system of relationships it is part of
here is again the Distilled of museum
this one by Carl Pucci and again you see
how the circle is activated in multiple
different ways throughout the field
condition of the plan
sometimes as interior space like here
and sometimes as outside space and
always as a structural hinge between
different plans systems every circle in
the plan becomes the geometric mediator
between different components of the plan
and also each one of them is intimately
related to the circulatory spaces you
also realize that the plan is based on
on a diagonal composition this is again
one of those instances where the
technique of representation and I mean
the suggestion of three dimensionality
in the exome as a design tool in the
studio is turned into the 2-dimensional
logic of the plan but she told me that
the plan is built on the 45-degree angle
because the building was designed in
axonometric view based on that angle and
this procedure was of course encouraged
by sterling the facades then are not as
consistent formally speaking as the
plans but talk to the idea of urban
heterogeneity in a more anecdotal way
suggesting the adjacency of very
abstract volumes with found objects of
the historic town or should I say
objection poetic in reference to the
Corbusier's occasional play with the
fragments of the historic city and then
he also Nessen
entire object buildings in the syntax of
the museum plan as if architecture was
an exhibition object in and of itself an
object on display on top of the plinth
and among other objects in the museum
put his building no doubt suggest the
metaphor of the ship looking out onto
the River Rhine the site is right next
to the river and next to a bridge
crossing the Rhine but the building also
is derived from gothic churches in
Dusseldorf with their flying buttresses
now reincarnated in surfaces of
articulated glass in fact bus-stop
windows these are bust up windows as he
told me but she also expressed that this
type of playful allusion to the medieval
town a German town and a slightly
ridiculous take on it was related to
Sterling's very ambivalent attitude
about Germany because he was someone who
had fought against Germany in the war
yesterday night caught foster
Illustrated how Sterling's relationship
to Germany was not an easy one and that
his not at all trustful approach to
Germany supplied sterling with a
different way of interpreting and
dealing with their country's past while
the Germans sanctioned certain licenses
from him precisely because he was
British nor over that part of put his
edifice is the 1975 precedent of the
building sterling designed 15 or 16
years later for the Giardini in Venice
right before his death the bookshop from
1991 which also alludes to the former
lexicon of ship construction the
analogies are perhaps more legible in
the front exon of put his building you
also realize that the steps and the
plinth are treated in very much the same
the same way in the two projects
separated by 16 years and if Pucci might
have given sterling the idea for his
future design in Venice he himself
appropriated from sterling here the
oblique glass roof from the history
faculty
in Oxford in [ __ ] scheme this glass
roof covers the atrium of the museum
entrance and you certainly noticed that
some of the historical facades have been
flipped from their traditional vertical
position into the horizontal they are
now lying flat on the ground which she
explained that once again this is
related to Sterling's war trauma the
window modules of the the facade flipped
into the ground plane now suggest a
gridded the gridded layout of a
graveyard and apparently a cemetery once
existed on this site and hence the
analogies between the finitude and the
historicity of architectural things and
of human bodies is as you suggested this
- you could argue runs parallel to John
Hay docks thought who even designed a
cemetery for the ashes of thought the
same year meaning in 1975 and who also
made the connection between vertical
time the time that is alive that is
still standing history that goes on and
the horizontal time the time that has
fallen or collapsed this in his
installation entitled collapse time that
was built only later in in 86 in
London's Bedford Square to commemorate
the victims of the Gestapo so it is
quite remarkable how Sterling's past
present and future emerge here in the
spatialized time of put his building and
it is hard to miss a certain sentiment
of tragedy related to the clustering of
different historical moments in the
synthetic gesture of architecture and
urbanism our school lived through its
own moment of tragedy when the aana
building was on fire in 1969 the
projects right prior to right prior to
the fire however in the second half of
the 1960s before I'm coming back to this
moment were characterized by an
unrestricted outpouring of optimism
dreaming up the future city as a utopia
of global communication and mobility for
young and fancy people
Doug Michaels
Arthur Goulding and Craig Hodges came up
with the blueprint of a city that has
been renewed from ground up from the
individual kitchen and bathroom capsules
to housing units and to a whole layout
for the city to come analogies between
the Machine inspired a bleakness of
hundreds and Sterling's buildings
certainly exist so this is Hodgins and
that is sterling from the same time this
is studying in 65 this is Hodgins in 66
the Dorman long headquarter of Steel
Corporation headquarters and also the
connection to our key Graham was of
course explicit with Hodgins as hard
said his project published in one of the
Archaea Graham issues
and you noticed a similar interest in
your bleakness but for Sterling the
oblique nurse would soon take on a
different connotation in Dobby when he
confronts the problem of historic over
historical town and when he becomes
interested in the notion of the passage
of time he takes the facade of the burnt
down burned down Assembly Hall and leans
it by 45 degrees and suggests the idea
of the hinge time between the historical
ground of the horizontal city of the
past and the present time of the
vertical facades that exist in the city
today Sterling was not interested in
making explicit political statements
with his architecture or brand claims
about intellectual resonance of his
artifacts in fact he stayed focused on
the Miche of the architect organizer of
programs and spaces it was a real
architects architect and in his lectures
he would just be reading the competition
brief and then say and this is what I
did and this is what I did next however
the more immediate political questions
Yale students forced him to confront
came from the home front of Yale in the
form of a rebellious spirit around the
Black Panther trials the fire in the A&A
building and the aftermath of Charles
Moore leaving the deanship in the early
1970s and this was when buddy Mir
suggested that for his project for the
Mellon Center in New Haven now the
Center for British art while he come he
would propose a reflective shoebox to
mirror
Yale's art gallery across Chapel Street
so this is travel Street this was a
political statement in the sense that
buddy mere questioned the self-involved
navel-gazing of art in academia and
suggested that art had lost its face or
should I say a personal facade and
character in its ivory tower existence
and the resulting social autism only a
big hole structure the alluring box
implying that the emptiness of
institutionalized art could only be
filled with the energy of public life in
an urban space that the museum's task
was ultimately to provide in its center
a space for people together to actively
generate a living culture the reflective
facade was an alternative way to address
the city's past but it wasn't Sterling's
no doubt as it issued his deep-rooted
belief in the geometrical foundation of
architecture which articulates its
volumes and surfaces not like here the
phenomenology of reflection Robert or
took the same studio in 1972 and he too
carved out the geometrical center of the
museum and gave it back to city life in
the form of a publicly accessible open
space in this project the void was
created by overlapping the footprint of
the Yale art gallery on top of his
museum plan and you could say that this
is a shot from from the fall when the
studio took place and you could say that
he might have been inspired by the by
the void that existed at that time but
he created that void by overlapping the
footprint of the the Art Gallery from
across the street and subtracting the
art galleries a spatial volume from the
program of the melon of his own man and
center the influence of the syntactic
experiments of the white architects is
more than apparent
and some of its members were also
attending the final jury yet there is
also an added element of the political
statement and expression of political
resistance which the whites explicitly
rejected and sterling too by the way if
not actively then just by not ever
mentioning any of it
the result is a completely fragmented
Museum building playing with its own
tradition of monumentality and authority
here is an institutional building that
both declares its presence in the city
and also simultaneously declares its
limits its doubts its vulnerability the
formal result could not have been much
further away from Sterling's own
solutions yet in spirit the idea of the
urban palimpsest and historicity the
emphasis on the public accessibility of
the museum the fundamental urban idea
behind the artifact as well as the
irreverence towards the jewelry box
ideology of the traditional Museum
anticipate Sterling's own views in the
later institutional projects this one
taken from the start's gallery we of
course the center of the music museum
becomes a public space I will try to
conclude you must be happy about that it
is important to first realize that
Sterling's influence on the students
changed between the early years up and
the early years I I think up to the late
1960s and then the later years starting
in 1970 I would say 283 you can
speculate that rudolf had such a strong
control over and also grip on what was
happening in the school and also
design-wise that sterling stayed more
distanced and reserved and he was less
hands-on and when you look at the
exhibition you will I think feel that
more who came in 66 or took the deanship
in 66 more on the contrary might have
created a more or less a fair atmosphere
where students functioned very
independently hence you get the result
we saw in those years if the students
didn't
the quality of their projects and their
drawings themselves they stayed very
basic and we received very uneven
documentation for those studio years in
quality and also in quantity and this
does reflect the atmosphere the school
was in in those years I think when
Herman Spiga comes in the early 1970s
things get more organized and sterling
is joined by studio coordinators Judy
Rowland Don Watson and later right
before Cesar Pelli takes over in 1977
Robert Livesey and Roger an ally Bob
Kahn and a few others join Sterling to
teach the studio's it appears that Dean
Pelle put a lot of emphasis on the
careful representation of the
architectural ideas for that reason but
also because Livesey joined Sterling as
a co teacher for for six years we sees a
certain professionalism in the studio's
lives he made sure that everybody was on
track of course Sterling's ideas about
architecture changed considerably
through these years and because of this
institutional context the version of
Sterling that was most influential on
Yale was disturbing that focused on the
connection between the building and the
city the Darby kind of sterling this
little Florence Stuttgart Dartmouth
Cornell and the like no one will be able
to hide the fact that that there are
striking parallels between Sterling's
own solutions and the student projects
this is more than apparent in the
exhibition upstairs I would say of
course this is neither inherently
problematic or fundamentally good it
just describes how sterling chose to run
his studios and there is no doubt in my
mind that Socratic self-reflection was
not the dominant mode in these studios
but that a certain modus operandi was
conveyed one that dealt with the
analysis of precedent and context and
that transmitted an ideology about how
the architecture of the present defines
itself in the tectonic bonds between
heterogeneous elements so the
architecture sterling taught in
Studios was not interested in a
zeitgeist the synthetic form in a formal
veneer that smoothened over difference
but on the contrary all these projects
make architecture look very spatial and
tectonic for the reason that it presents
itself as the witty art of joinery and
combination of architectural ingredients
taken from past and present moment and
moment in time to analyze the student
project in Sterling Studios does not
help you understand where the students
would take architecture in their own in
their later lives you would be surprised
how far some are removed from any of
this but arguably such an analysis makes
us better understand what drove
architecture in those years that start
to take on more and more texture in
contemporary historiography and that are
characterized by a definite sense of
loss produced by modernism and by
modernity as understanding of historical
time or I should say lack thereof
architecture becomes an art of tectonic
combination once again but one that has
to hold together a world that is
fundamentally heterogeneous and diverse
and that cannot rely on unified
solutions thank you
Thank You Emmanuel for whatever I say a
mystery analysis
survivors of the period they already but
right in there we need the mic
I love my voice holds but it's I quite
enjoy do it's done I quite enjoyed your
the way you set off the talk with being
this you know normally enjoy see and
this the first side view and you know
the real and engagement of it the real
and the ideal and it's interesting is
one thing that I've been struggling you
know listening to all the talk and
visiting the show with sterling that
even when he engage is the real and the
context and the urbanism you know it is
something so creepily the tired detached
I mean you just so how it doesn't get to
the crowd and I mean you never see the
space you said that he was dissing
that's interested in the kind of
phenomenological aspect of building you
never see a perspective you never see
that you know and I was just wondering
you know how does that talk about his
legacy and where we can you know take
that in you know in terms of that
detachment or I don't know maybe other
people don't see it that way maybe you
don't see well I'm not sure what you
mean when you say it's no I mean the
whole kind of you know the the the the
axonometric in itself that the building
is always viewed in in in this sort of
kind of analytical mode but that's
exactly the point
and as always there are always these two
sites that on the one hand yes you get
the impression of distance that this
ideal thing floating up there and at the
same time when you look at these
fragmentary axons you get these these
you know debris of reality that I
inserted on in fact it's a no graphics
page yeah I get I get that but I feel
that I'd you know it never gets there it
never gets to the real I mean if there's
a balance of real and representation
it's it under in favor of representation
that it never gets to the real it never
it always remains the attached anecdotal
ironic it never kind of gets to the real
even though in even on the tectonic
level that might say more about what you
are looking for in architecture than it
says about I mean in your in your book
and and maybe studying did not share
that one and of course there is there's
always the sense of this there's always
the stage right the the shrink desk in
fact that Germans in a graphic stage
we'd be putting in the stage and then
fragments on top of the stage that
doesn't go away from staring now you
call it ironic I agree yes but that is
stunning and I think that is exactly
that note that that stage is hovering
between the wheel and the idea and that
is what is so interesting and so
specific about study if you want
authenticity maybe no it's I don't want
though everyone you know I'm not that's
not what what I'm getting at but even
when you look at show see you you see
that kind of struggle between the
abstraction and you know the way that
joycie deals with with the real and the
tectonics and the abstraction and
somehow that is kind of it has this sort
of it gets at both
you know I feel that you know the
steering doesn't even when he represents
building the buildings it never gets to
the kind of level of spatial I
understand I hear an underlying
frustration that you have with study but
if you want to do thank you for for the
lecture I wanted to ask you since you've
been so clean all these grassroots
researching in depth of that period in
of the school and I know because I saw
you two weeks ago and midterms in almost
all the the juries and you know how
things are working now here could you
maybe elaborate on the differences
between the schools in that time and
today
I'm not worried about my contract and I
I don't know I mean in a sense you know
this is a very tricky question to answer
because just might my experience of
today about representation is there the
same reflection on the guy who can
conceptualize dad but I I would say that
when you look at the drawings up there
and also in studies drawings that they
have an inherent sense of space yeah I
mean they are very special and and I
think that today we are kind of fighting
with the computer to get a similar sense
of space out of 2d drawings even out of
high schools and perspectives and and so
sterling just because there are always
coming together that creates space
whereas we tend to it that's part of our
way of thinking today we smooth over and
the drawing stay they turn flat
I'm not saying good or bad I'm saying
that something has changed but there was
a different demand on what a drawing
would represent Sterling wasn't
functional
well it I think a sign of a good talk
that it provoked a lot of questions and
thoughts that I have but just a few of
them randomly strung together first of
all we all want to know what happened to
Dean Stern sideburns sideburns didn't
fall out though secondly just that in
again in no particular order and except
maybe speaking to Avis Point having
suffered through some of those
worm's-eye acts and metric constructions
which were just helped to produce
because they constantly flipped on you
as you made them and they still do when
you put them on the screen which is
quite amazing
they're also I mean not only is it was e
it's also engineering drawings and I
think that culture was also quite
powerful for for Jim in both an
ideological way and in a personal way
and the cutaway acts those at least in
his work and in some of the students
work are always chosen I mean I think
there's a difference gyms are often
chosen almost always chosen to show the
promenade to show the workings of
circulation as if it were the inside of
a machine whereas I thought it was quite
powerful that you pointed out that some
of the students drawings are constructed
in a very different spirit to show the
solidity of the volumes in the space
more Hajduk like in that respect the
other thing that might be interesting to
do and maybe you've done it already is
to look in parallel at what the students
were publishing in perspective at the
same time and I I recall watching the
the transformation of the work that
before collage City was published as a
book the Yale students published a big
section of it in fact I think the
central chapter the crisis of the object
has a long prose poem in an issue of
perspective and I think that was right
in the heart of all the the Stuttgart
dusseldorf work which was very closely
associated with the themes of a book
that had not yet come out yet but was
obviously circulating as we all knew at
the time in various various forms so
there they're just all these fascinating
strands and then one final observation
the sort of unholy alliance in some of
the that work in the 70s between a very
thin Charles Moore version of
architecture and the much weightier more
robust serling version of architecture
produce some gramatically quite
challenged schemes and among the way I
thought you were very nice to them in
your description but the efforts of the
students to somehow reconcile what they
must have learned a year or two before
from Charles and his Alcala his students
with what Jim had to offer didn't always
kind of come together in the most
satisfying way
we still like that atmosphere right
Emmanuel and I like very much what you
did with the drawings but I was
surprised that you didn't use models at
all any of the models that represent his
buildings and I think that sometimes
they tell a very different story than
the one you've told us with the drawings
so I just wanted to see what you said
about the relationship to the models
well I have a very pragmatic answer of
course well in the British art centre in
the British art centre there's lots of
them
yes no no no not students I agree
they're not students
in the school either in the school I
mean in the school that he did not they
did not that they didn't use models did
they not make models but that was never
too
did sterling use his office projects to
help him think through his studio
projects or vice versa or both starting
in 1970 the projects that he assigned in
industry were all projects that he had
that he was working on with his office
and always a few months ahead of the
studio so it's safe to believe that that
there were ideas you know crossing
boundaries between between the office
and the studio I would think that's how
architecture has always operated
first prize was for the school team that
was most like the one he is actually
doing the second prize definitely what's
the back and forth
the price was a tight no I was a rich
bride but the second prize was the
beautiful Turnbull & Asser sure
David partner David Wagner for this
business partner Mike wall who showed
his okay